thank you Wow flicka's oh look at all
the people thank you very much I know
why you're happy tonight Trump still
licking his wounds about his bad rally
turnout in Tulsa who saw that [ __ ] oh my
god you know he expected a big crowd who
his 19,000 would fit in the building
6,000 showed up and you know Trump all
about the big number so when he got wind
that the count might be light he said to
his aides
I want you to put asses in seats and
that's when they let his supporters in I
say good luck to his supporters but yeah
he was bragging all week before this but
that a million to a million people he
said requested tickets it turns out
there were teenagers who were bugging
him they were kpop stands trolling him
it's like Hitler being taken down by the
lollipop guild
I mean a million people and then 6,000
show up he was let's see 994 thousand
short and of course they were wearing no
masks these these are what you call
diehard fans because at their age and
then the health they're in they're gonna
die hard yeah I would not recommend it
that's your health profile you go to a
Trump probably like that but yeah I mean
he spent 15 minutes in the rally
relitigated ramp game he's obsessed with
this thing that happened a couple of
weeks ago we was going down a ramp and
it did not go well and so he's making
excuses it was the shoes and the no
handrail it was slippery it turns out
he's not a doddering top-heavy fat-ass
who remained upright because his diaper
was full it's their shows
then he rambled on for another two hours
I'm telling you his fans when they came
in they weren't afraid of the virus by
the end of it they were begging for him
so this is the most insane thing that
happened in a long time he asked his
staff if even by his standards to slow
the testing down he said if we have less
testing we will record less cases yes
but they'll still be there
so his bootlickers of course had to say
the next day he was just joking
forgetting the first rule of Trump
he's only unintentionally funny this
happens all the time he says something
insane and then his people go oh it's
kidding and then the next day he goes
I'm not kidding
it's that can happen Costello routine if
both Abbot and Costello were of
compulsive liars
but okay the good news Biden up by 14
points I mean 14 points is a lot it
turns out Biden strategy of running
against the worst person currently alive
on earth is really paying off
Trump camp says they are not worried
Putin loves a challenge but of course
you know their strategy Trump is already
saying that the election in November is
rigged it's rigged
he said millions of mail-in ballots will
be printed by foreign countries and you
know there's one thing Donald Trump will
not stand for and that's foreigners
meddling in an American election so
after all this horrible week he had he
decides okay what I'm gonna do is make
up in the Tulsa Fiasco and have another
rally in Arizona this time in a much
smaller venue you know downsizing so
that [ __ ] doesn't happen again so he
goes to Arizona and the other day 3,000
people very intimate he did some
acoustic racism this rally in a
megachurch and right before the church's
leaders the megachurches leaders
released this video where they said they
installed a technology that kills 99.9%
of Kovan within ten minutes of course
people were like what and then they said
come on when have we ever manipulated
you with unsubstantiated [ __ ]
[Applause]
even the penis enlargement people were
like what
you